Traduttore: Giorgio Fighera
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Tutto nasce quando avevo 18 anni.
Facevo... ero uno scolaro,
un umile scolaro.
Nel maggio di quell'anno feci un sogno.
Ero seduto su una sedia,
di fronte a me c'era il computer,
di fianco a me c'era il sassofono.
Ero legato. Imprigionato.
Guardavo il video,
e potevo allungare la mano
e riuscire a schiacciare
i tasti del computer.
Ma quando mi giravo
e cercavo il sassofono,
non potevo arrivarci.
E piangevo, piangevo, piangevo.
Questo sogno era fortissimo.
Il giorno dopo mi sono svegliato
e ho deciso di non andare più a scuola.
Pazzo.
E dedicare la mia vita,
adesso ho 50 anni,
32 anni, alla musica.
A 24 anni a un certo punto arriva il canto
che mi da la sensazione probabile
di portare al di fuori di me
quelle emozioni che forse il sassofono
non riusciva a darmi.
Ho camminato nel canto,
adesso in questi 50 anni,
penso che la vita mi
conceda sempre l'opportunità
di uscire fuori da
quella zona e di sognare.
Quel sogno che mi è ancora
ben chiaro di quei 18 anni,
è racchiuso in questa parola:
the soundteller.
Cercare di raccontare
la mia storia con dei suoni,
questa è una sfida che ho cercato
e probabilmente la maturità,
in questo momento,
mi permette di portare questo a voi.
La prima riflessione
che vorrei fare è la nascita.
La nascita ci porta a respirare.
Quanti respiri facciamo al giorno?
Circa ventimila.
Pochi o tanti che siano.
Il respiro ormai fa parte di noi,
forse non ci pensiamo.
A un certo punto della mia vita,
ho deciso di scrivere
un pezzo dedicato al respiro.
Fatto di respiri, fatto di emozioni
in base al respiro.
Ve lo faccio vedere lentamente
quello che accadrà
perché poi la successione dell'esercizio
sarà abbastanza veloce.
È un susseguirsi di respiri.
(Respiri)
(Applausi)
È un viaggio, la mia vita è un viaggio.
Sì sì sì, a 24 anni ero lì,
pronto per camminare, camminare.
C'era un certo Demetrio Stratos,
gioia e rivoluzione.
Sì, ho voglia di fare rivoluzione.
Sono andato avanti, ho cercato.
Ho incontrato Bobby Mc Ferryn,
don't worry, be happy.
Avevo un sogno nella mia vita,
incontrarlo e cantare insieme a lui.
Ce l'ho fatta, sì,
un altro sogno avverato.
Cosa faccio, adesso? Dove vado?
Ho imparato, nella mia vita,
a non stare nella mia zona di comfort.
Non mi piace, dopo un po' mi è stretta.
Allora faccio così, guardate.
Un salto,
e vado nella zona di non comfort.
E nella zona di non comfort soffro,
sorrido, guadagno dei -
forse piccoli tasselli che mi
portano avanti nella mia vita.
Oggi, come vedete, viaggiamo
probabilmente con un tempo molto veloce,
e in questo frangente, cercherò
di portarvi in un mondo
che chissà quale sarà.
Il primo compito vostro sarà fare questo:
(suono di gocce)
Sentite la pioggia che cade?
Anche non a tempo.
Prendetevi il vostro tempo, gustatevi il:
(suono di goccia)
Questo ci porterà nel viaggio.
Il primo viaggio
è...
Non smettete!
Vi presento il mio primo amico,
si chiama "I-paddino".
Ai-Pad-Dino.
Nome: "I-paddino".
Lei è Carlotta,
una loop station umile.
505 è il suo numero.
Attenzione che vi interrogo,
sempre con la pioggia eh!
(Applausi)
Il dialogo.
Dialogare.
Ah, quanto mi piace parlare con voi.
Siete pronti?
Ci proviamo, eh!
Conto in voi.
Facciamo un grido per dire: ci siamo.
- Uno, due, tre...
- Ci siamo!
Allora cambiamo compito.
Abbiamo tre settori.
Primo settore, lettera T.
Con questo suono: Tiii...
Secondo settore: E.
Eeee...
Tiii...
(Eeee...)
Diii...
Ve le ricordate le note?
Che spettacolo.
Allora, al mio cenno,
cantate la vostra lettera.
Vediamo che cosa avviene.
La prima cosa che avverrà,
andremo indietro nel tempo, sì.
Quel tempo in cui la musica italiana
faceva breccia nella nostra Europa.
Sì, andiamo indietro.
(Canto)
Ricordiamoci le note.
(Risate)
Tiiii - Eeee - Diiii
X
(Risate e applausi)
Il tempo scorre.
Per un improvvisatore,
stare dentro 15 minuti
è veramente pazzesco.
È come metterlo dentro una gabbia.
Ma...
sono arrivato al dunque.
Ce l'ho fatta.
Ho voluto accettare,
al compimento dei miei 50 anni,
la richiesta di venire
su questo cerchio rosso.
E mettermi in discussione, sì,
raccontando la mia storia.
Vi ho dato poco, probabilmente,
di questi 50 anni.
Ma ho cercato di darvi
tutto quello che ho.
Perché penso che la mia vita sia ancora,
a 50 anni, aver voglia di giocare.
Sì, ho voglia di giocare,
ho voglia di buttarmi per terra,
ho voglia di rialzarmi.
Ho voglia di soffrire
e di divertirmi e gioire.
Ogni giorno, per i giovani
cerco di
portare speranza con
l'insegnamento del canto.
Entro in una classe,
e cerco di guardare negli occhi,
e di percepire quello
che l'altro mi sta consegnando.
Vi dico una cosa e ve la concedo.
Se avete dei figli, fateli cantare.
Se avete dei figli, avvicinateli all'arte.
E quello che vi posso dire è:
continuiamo a giocare,
perché forse è la bellezza dell'uomo.
Ciao ciao.
(Applausi)